- Hallo, Inge! Du bist
aus dem Urlaub zurück.
- Ja. Und du?
Was gibt's bei dir Neues, Nico?
- Nico wird bald bei Yara im Fahrradladen
eine Ausbildung machen.
- Wirklich? Das ist ja toll!
- Das wird eine harte Zeit, Nico.
Das weißt du hoffentlich.
- Wieso?
- Yara ist eine harte Chefin. Du wirst
Tag und Nacht arbeiten müssen.
- Bei uns wäre das anders gewesen.
Du hättest im Restaurant die Zeit
deines Lebens haben können.
- Lass dir nichts einreden!
- Das stimmt. Zumindest im Winter.
- Im Sommer ist wegen der vielen Gäste
draußen auch mehr Betrieb.
- Aber im Winter ist es im Fahrradladen
ja auch ruhiger:
Wegen des Wetters fährt ja
fast niemand Fahrrad.
- Du wirst dich wundern!
- Wir zumindest fahren bei Schnee
und Eis mit dem Fahrrad.
Es tut uns leid, Nico, aber du wirst
nie wieder Freizeit haben.
- Dafür gibt es im Sommer wegen der
Hitze am Mittag eine Siesta.
- Hahaha. In Spanien vielleicht.
- Du wirst deine Gewohnheiten
ändern müssen.
- Also ich finde Siesta super.
- Ja, vielleicht machen wir eine Siesta.
Dann können wir Nico im Fahrradladen
besuchen, denn er muss mittags arbeiten.
- Ich weiß nicht, was mit denen
heute los ist.
- Zu viel Arbeit ...